i think
the first thing i say about reyes is we
just don't know
the second thing i'll say is what we do
know is that he called for storming the
capital and he's not being criminally
charged he's being protected he's being
he's been protected by the media and by
and adam kings or kinzinger defended him
online the question then becomes why we
have no evidence to explain what their
motivation is we can only surmise at the
very least a plausible minimum
non-conspiratorial responses ray apps
may have been the first guy the feds
went after because he was on the live
stream saying it they made it may have
been looking at him right away a deal
made a deal with him immediately
it could have been
the night before he's on a live stream
telling people to storm the capitol i
imagine this before anything happened
feds could have went right to him in the
hotel and said you're going to wear a
wire you're going to give us names and
you work for us now as a ci
and that's why after the fact you don't
see him getting charged not that he's a
federal agent but that he may have been
an informant after the fact now that's a
minimum maybe there's something else
beyond this
i just don't know what i do know is it
is very strange that they're putting
people in solitary they're charging them
with seditious conspiracy but the guy
who's literally on camera telling people
to do it telling them how to do it
hasn't been charged tim maga granny
there's a grandma in there with her
little flag and she's a hardened
criminal they actually think she's going
to be able to overthrow the government
the photo of the one with the little
flag was from i think madison but there
is currently a 69 year old cancer
patient cancer patient going to 60 years
60 years 60 days in jail and you know
why they just passed and you know why
the judge said that because the judge
had let somebody else off and they went
on fox news and didn't show remorse but
in the courtroom they did show remorse
so because of somebody else's conviction
she got a 60 days 69 year old cancer
patient so that's where we're at that's
why i'm saying
so the funny thing is and i'm glad aoc
uh
set the doors open by police because
that is a huge huge
powerful political point and uh uh i
will say i am shocked that it is the
result of you calling aoc a big booty
latina well we don't know it's the
result no it it is it is and reality is
stranger than fiction tim you have to
realize that this is important because
there are many people like the 69 year
old cancer patient uh pamela hemphill by
that it was miss him i don't know her
specific story but i really doubt the 69
year old cancer patient was fighting
with police officers
she's probably one of the people who saw
the door open and walked in very
casually and she was on medical
marijuana probably so she didn't even
know where she was at i'm just kind of
just kidding because the police opened
the door
in more than one location police at the
capitol building open the doors there's
even an instance where the police fanned
people in and a man was acquitted on all
counts because he showed a video to the
judge of him being motioned in by the
officer so he was acquitted for that
there were there was more than one door
that was open there was an instance
where the cop said he respected what the
people were doing and there's instances
where the cops took selfies with people
so now this woman is going to jail for
60 days after she was potentially
invited in or some people were
these people need to be pardoned across
the board for this ridiculous
misdemeanor stuff and it is powerful
extremely powerful now that aoc said the
doors were opened that needs that clip
needs to be i i don't know should i take
that clip and i should should i buy tv
commercials honestly hey but let's not
forget ashley babbitt probably let in by
a capital police officer gets shot and
murdered and she was a veteran she's
somebody that loved their country so
much and she just gets thrown under the
rug as some evil person so not only did
you know these people get let in but
some people got murdered
i i think maybe we do a um i have to
figure out how to do it there's a lot of
things i want to do that never happen
unfortunately which i don't like
bringing it i don't like saying we want
to do things if we don't have a means to
actually get it done but i would love to
see a commercial where it's like
alexandria ocasio-cortez says that there
were cops and other people who opened
the doors to let that in on january 6
and has called for an investigation
we agree with alexandria ocasio-cortez
support the calls for an investigation
into who opened the doors at the capitol
building can you play that video let me
see if uh she's got to be regretting
that's quite right or not i think she's
being very serious and it is disturbing
aoc big booty is the first thing that
aggregates
may have let
if police let people in and those people
that were let in are in solitary
confinement it is inane it is it is
abjunked to american democracy i just
want to say real quick my video
talking about aoc and the big booty
thing was age restricted
on youtube what the video where i talked
about
big booty latina and all that stuff they
age restricted adult term
here's here's here's the video clip
let's listen
let's uh wait on this time i'm going to
make sure we have the audio set properly
before i press play like antifa and that
there were actual officers working with
this and we never got to the bottom of
that and we never got any answers about
that and then to this day we're just
supposed to pretend that that never
happened
i have no idea what happened to the
people on the inside who were very
clearly sympathetic with what was going
on and opening the doors wide open for
that and where i'm supposed to sit here
and pretend like none of that ever
happened and then right afterwards you
have a massive you know you just have
this idea that throwing money at that
problem is going to make it go away we
could burn somebody accountability and
so this is this is where these things
are breaking down we're not safe and
it's not just about members of congress
not being safe the food staff workers
are insane the janitors aren't safe like
we need to get to the bottom of that yes
so i'd love to get like a commercial of
like a 60 year old man being like
alexandria ocasio-cortez says people on
the inside opened the door this is what
happened when you talk to her when you
approach her on the steps she was with a
capital police officer that didn't get
in your way and stop you and now she's
questioning is that guy on the is that
guy and she's wondering if they're like
traitors in the building whatever her
reasoning is
it's important that we find out if
people let people into the building
because those people are in solitary
confinement right now and that's ian do
you think they had a key i mean how do
you think they opened i saw a magnetic
lock on a door get opened i saw the
video of a cop look at it i don't know
right someone off camera yep and it was
a police officer that like looked up and
then you think these these these dudes
who are like trying to break a window to
get in know where the mag release is and
you know you don't think there's some of
those cops that probably were
sympathetic to what's happening sure i
mean she's obviously correct and i don't
i don't care what the end result is
maybe the end result is like members of
congress we're in on it good whatever
let's have an investigation and who
opened those doors i'm if there were
members of congress that were
orchestrating the opening of the door to
bring people in to disrupt this then we
should find out who did that and why i
think
all of these bumbling daughters these
old people the maga mimos who just saw a
clear path and cops waving them in who
walked in and now have their lives
destroyed should be pardoned those
people should have never been charged
that was a fault of capital police and
the government
i won an investigation of the cops
opened the doors if they didn't open the
doors this wouldn't have happened well
and your bestie joe rogan talks about
one of his favorite things that alex
jones did he exposed the wto about in i
believe in seattle where there were
agent provocateurs who stayed in a
building and you know basically they
were all wearing the same boots and and
agent provocateurs exist now you're
going to say oh none of them were on
january 6. we have evidence of people
using agent provocateurs to make a riot
look bad that's that's a playbook it's
kind of similar to operation northwoods
or so you know as a declassified thing
where they're going to take planes and
fly them into buildings or in the cuban
missile crisis and then 911 was kind of
similar to that but what i'm saying is
if you do not think the government has
classified levels of information and is
creating a narrative by using their own
military cia fbi whatever you want to
call it alphabet agencies in order to
make things look worse than they really
are
you know you might be a conspiracy
because it's a reason to get more
funding for more security apparatus to
grow the security it's a false flag
attack guys and this is a false flag
attack playbook i mean you know i could
be wrong i'm not saying that i know
everything but just all of the evidence
when we see ray apps and we see the way
the media is protecting them it's hard
for me to imagine that this was all just
accidental yeah it could be a hybrid of
like people getting angry and going to
the capitol storming
and people trying to benefit off it by
making it come out worse as a result so
it could be both i think if it is
uh in that vein of false flag it's more
so that they allowed it to happen and
that's why there's video of police
officers not intervening there's a guy
walking up to cops being like why won't
you stop this and the cops are like we
don't care
it's it it explains more so why there
was no national guard no heavy police
presence why their claim like trump said
he wanted the national guard there and
they rejected it so if i'll put it this
way
on 5 29
the left insurrected they tried to take
they did tear down the barricades of the
white house they set fire to saint
john's church and the and the guard post
they forced the president into a bunker
if the police there
stood down
and they tore the fences down or
breached the white house
there would not be a 1-6 donald trump
would be president donald trump there
would have been a major statement there
had been far-left extremists have
breached the white house americans would
have been terrified they would have said
this is insane and then the conversation
would have been
the police saying things like we stood
down because
we did not want to hurt people and we
didn't know how to react to this level
but what happens is the police go out
do their job and clear that clear the
space and the and the response from the
media and the democrats was to
investigate the police over it
they said the capital police should be
investigated for attacking protesters
that's how it went down on january 6
because the police let everyone do
everything it's oh oh geez the police
were the poor victims and these are the
bad guys it's it's the very it's the
very typical i'm the victim narrative
that that is manipulative is used to
manipulate people and it is potentially
possible that that's that was happening
like the cops like there's 700 screaming
people i'm not getting involved are you
kidding me like that could probably also
have been part of it
i wouldn't you know i wouldn't get i
mean what are you gonna do you get
mobbed if that happens thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast irl
come hang out live monday through friday
at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time